hey guys today we're going to talk about
a very unconventional uncommon counterintuitive
fatty liver cleansing tip okay
before I get into the tip I just want to
give you some basics about the liver the
liver is about three and a half pounds
it sits over on the right side right
about here it has 500 different
functions here's the problem when
someone develops a fatty liver there is
virtually no symptoms at all now you
start to develop a gut but it's very
rare to have symptoms until it starts
becoming more advanced and then
eventually the person starts getting
fatigued weak nausea abdominal pain
right shoulder pain pain in the upper
right trap maybe some headaches on the
right side pain in the right rhomboid
back here but what happens is you have
this fatty liver and then eventually
after years of inflammation you get
cirrhosis and this is scar tissue now
builds up in the liver and in this
process you basically lose function of
the liver you lose the ability to
detoxify okay so you build up toxic
waste you also build up excessive
amounts of cortisol because the liver is
the organ to help buffer and regulate
excessive amounts of cortisol that's the
stress hormone this is one of the causes
to a an adrenal fatigue problem also you
start building up excessive amounts of
estrogen this can manifest as many
different things one man boobs a woman
that's estrogen dominant you can have
cancer so a functional liver is really
important in the detoxification and
regulation of these two hormones right
here the other problem is when you have
less function of the liver you get less
bile production and if you're not
producing a bile
you can't break down toxic waste you
can't break down fats you can't actually
absorb vitamin A D e K omega-3 fatty
acids and the list goes on and on and on
now there's two different categories of
a fatty liver one would be caused from
drinking too much alcohol the other one
is not the other one is a non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease you can develop that
from eating very poorly and the big
thing that causes a fatty liver
would be fructose in the form of
high-fructose corn syrup
it's in the sodas it's in the food in
fact fructose is 20 times more likely to
cause of fatty liver than any other
sugars and as far as the non-alcoholic
fatty liver disease 25 percent of the
population actually has this but not
just overweight people not just people
with a gut skinny people are twice as
likely to die from a fatty liver then
overweight people probably because
they're skinny and they think they're
healthy and they can eat whatever they
want so they do eat whatever they want
now this next point was quite
interesting there's actually many
studies on this but here's what happens
when mice are fed methionine and choline
deficient diets they get a fatty liver
but they don't gain weight they don't
get insulin resistance or diabetes they
just get a fatty liver the thine eyne is
an amino acid in choline is an essential
nutrient in the B vitamin family and the
thine eyne is a precursor a building
block to the most powerful antioxidant
in the body which is called glutathione
which is a software-based compound that
helps you break down chemicals and
choline is a called a lipid trophic
nutrient it actually dissolves fat in
the body and it can actually strip off
fat from your liver so now let's get
into the counterintuitive tip I'm going
to talk about typically when you think
about liver cleansing or getting rid of
a liver problem you're thinking of
juicing a vegetable cleanse consuming
low fats consuming lower amounts meats
things like that however when you do
that you only get a certain amount of
results because check this out the foods
that are loaded with choline are egg
yolks
liver grass-fed dairy and cruciferous
vegetable okay math I'm you have beef
chicken pork nuts fish eggs so two of
the most important nutrients in
correcting or reversing a fatty liver
involve foods
higher in fat and protein so if you want
to cleanse and heal a fetid liver you
don't want to go low-fat you don't want
to keep your protein too low moderate
protein not excessive but you don't want
to start cutting out all these foods
right here so instead of doing juicing
or only vegetables you should do a
combination of the cruciferous
vegetables and fattier proteins
including egg yolks and fish of course
make sure they're grass-fed now there's
two goals with detoxifying a fatty liver
one is to get rid of the toxins of
course because the liver has a function
of detoxification so the cruciferous
vegetables are loaded with the
phytonutrients to help create this
effect and by the way certain animal
products organ meats fish seafood also
have antioxidants to help remove toxins
from your liver it's not just vegetables
so we want to actually do something to
get rid of the toxins as well as get rid
of the fat and to do this you must lower
your carbs and this is why healthy keto
the healthy version of keto is necessary
and that basically means the concept of
low carb with a lot of vegetables so
that would be essential and then of
course in a minute fasting why because
of intermittent fasting forces your body
to use up your glycogen Reserve and to
run off fat so it kind of creates a
vacuum to pull the fat out of the body
and that's what's needed to start to
deplete the fat in the liver I also
suggest that you take choline as a
supplement you can get methionine from
the protein and you can also get choline
but if you take some extra choline I
recommend about 4 to 500 milligrams
you can even go as high as 3,000
milligrams if you want but typically I
always start out about 300 to 400
milligrams of choline you can get in a
tablet or get into powder and start
consuming that what that will do it will
start to dissolve the fat and the liver
and speed up the process so of course we
want to add the crisps
I would recommend steaming or slightly
cooking these because that will release
more vital nutrients eggs are essential
for the choline quality protein of
course don't get this at 7-eleven go to
the health of store and increase the
quality and the last point I want to
bring up which is really important is if
you try to cleanse the liver especially
if it's a fatty liver with a low fat
diet you will not have enough bile to
help detoxify it one of the functions of
bio is detoxification so bile is not
just about absorbing fats on the
vitamins it is about making sure the
liver can purge some of the toxic wastes
and what triggers bile higher amounts of
saturated fats this is why you want to
keep consuming egg yolks maybe even
organ meats and moderate amounts of
protein to make sure you release the
bile and you don't become deficient in
methionine or choline alright guys well
thank you so much for watching if you're
liking this content please subscribe now
and I will actually keep you updated on
future videos